if you're wondering what the most ironic
job you could have well fasting for
Ramadan is it's probably delivering the
food I work for one of these apps it's a
nightmare
every delivery is like the worst porn
ever the delivery guy shows up to the
milfs mansion she answers the door and
then she just takes the food and shuts
the door by the way if you order vegan
food delivered to your house at rush
hours sorry it's not vegan because an
animal suffered bringing it to you hey
your food's ready
nice but I eat something I can it's
Ramadan
how are you delivering food do a Ramadan
because of God I think we're going to
have sex one day it'll be so awkward I'm
a baby or Jewish Muslim ass and pork
juice and then I'm gonna wrap you in a
corn tortilla okay I funky bye baby
Thank You mr. Trump thank you for
joining us listen I don't hate Muslims I
love muscles I went to Muslim I met the
king I saw his castle beautiful castle
interesting you like Muslims that's
different than what you said on the
campaign trail do you care to comment on
the Muslim ban
I never said Muslim man I said I wanted
to start a Muslim band okay that's my
bad on a la carte
I would play the hookah scene though you
blamed Islam for radical Islamic
terrorism which is the same thing as
flame every sperm in your dad's balls
for how stupid you turned out
do you care to comment on that mr.
trauma we lost him
Donald President Donald President Donald
[Music]
Azari
I can eat in one hour